yes yes
yes yes from magnifico we wanted to take
inspiration from the classic Disney
villains and my favorite movies are the
ones that have those great villains that
you know from the beginning and every
great villain needs a great
song and that launched
into this is the thanks I
get our songwriters delivered something
very special are you ready
they want a villain you got one brought
to you by Chris Pine Chris Pine is funny
charming and incredible you're cute and
strong and bold and brave thanks Chris
broad gravitas and
comedy just look I greated 14 wishes
last year come on that's a high percent
and now you're questioning your king
disrespect I just under you know I
always got your back yeah really though
it's no sweat since the day you were
born born in the day that we met and
this is the thanks I Chris has a
beautiful range he can really go there
and he does a potion a spell a summon a
curse anything to make that light
reverse to this book I don't want to be
tether but desperate times call for
desperate
measures where was I oh yeah and this is
the thanks I get it's so classic epic
and fresh at the same time this is the
thanks I to see it fully animated I
cried because I was just like wow there
it is it's alive the than I
[Applause]
got R PGA